welcome to the man of recaps this is the
flash season seven at the end of season
six the evil eva mcculloch had just
escaped from the mirror verse iris is
still trapped in there and the flash is
losing his speed because the speed force
died the team is trying to create an
artificial speed force but so far no
luck but if anyone can figure out how to
build an artificial speed force it's
harrison wells remember since crisis
nashville's the indiana jones type is
the only wells left but all the other
wells are in his head so working
together they figure it out and turns
out to make it work they're gonna have
to sacrifice themselves oh put the
spirits of the wells's into the speed
force it's a touching moment as all the
different wells we've come to love over
six seasons say a farewell to barry run
berry run flash got his speed back but
we're not done with wells yet remember
the original earth one harrison wells
had his face stolen by the reverse flash
earmar thon but now for fake science
reasons i can't even begin to explain
the original earth one harrison wells is
back he introduces himself to team flash
but he's not sticking around apparently
he has time travel powers so he's going
back to retire with his wife and
harrison wells is off the show remember
the reverse flash eobard thon created
his own artificial speed force but it's
the negative speed force powered by
negative emotions so instead of that
team flash created a neutral speed force
but it has a side effect barry's lost
all of his emotions he's an unfeeling
robot long story short he figures out
how to get iris out of the mirror verse
but then she realizes she's gotta put
her love into that speed force so now
barry's super speed is literally powered
by his and iris's love anyway mirror
lady has some dastardly planned to
replace all of central city with mirror
clones flash busts into fighter but he
ends up defeating her with his real
super power emotional heart to hearts
that convince villains to become good
guys so eva goes back to quiet
retirement in the mirror verse and the
day is saved now it's not just harrison
wells leaving team flash this season
ralph dibny the elongated man is leaving
too yes the actor was fired from the
show for inappropriate tweets from 10
years ago it's an incredibly awkward
farewell where they make up an excuse
why he can't show his face and his voice
sounds different honestly it would have
been better if they didn't even bother
and just said he's off doing things and
cisco ramon get more serious with his
girlfriend camilla in fact they decide
that they want to leave central city yes
cisco also leaves team flash this season
he takes a job at argus what is
happening but he's been training his
replacement chester p runk who we met
last season he now officially takes over
as team flash's tech guy and he brings
with him his own cool vibe remember team
flash got another new addition last
season allegra garcia she and her evil
cousin esperanza both have ultraviolet
light powers but working with team flash
allegra got herself some of those super
love powers she redeems her cousin into
a good guy but almost immediately after
she dies one episode it's a crossover
with john diggle from arrow he's having
bad headaches though remember at the end
of arrow season 8 there was a teaser
scene where he found a green lantern
ring so assuming vcw for shows continue
john diggle gonna be the green lantern
then team flash gets another new member
kind of because killer frost and caitlyn
separate bodies i can't even begin to
explain the science of why this happens
but in any case frost and caitlyn no
longer sharing a body but still sharing
an apartment but sergeant kristen kramer
comes to town and she doesn't care that
frost is a good guy now she wants to
charge her with her crimes from when she
was still a villain in fact central said
he has a new ice-powered villain it's
this bartender who goes by chill blaine
who's got like ice gloves or whatever
and while he has cold powers he is super
hot frost has a huge lady boner for him
eventually though frost turns herself in
but kramer's pushing for a severe
penalty she wants to give her the
meta-human cure frost can't let that
become legal precedent she's like hey
i'd rather you lock me up for life papa
joe west won't stand for this gross
miscarriage of justice he resigns as
police chief turns out this whole plot
was pointless though like two episodes
later she's released for good behavior
now why does sergeant cramer hate meta
humans so much well when she was in the
army her best friend is a meta human who
betrayed them apparently he has
invincible powers but he's like yo girl
you're a meta human too turns out her
superpower is mimicking the powers of
other metas around her so watch out for
that now you can't have a season of the
flash without gorilla grodd except turns
out you can cause he's not in this
season they wasted their cgi budget on
this thing yes going back to the night
when iris put her love into the
artificial speed force there was an
unexpected consequence turns out that
brought the real speed force back to
life but it also created other forces of
nature that are bad this hulked out high
school wrestler is the strength force
they call forza there's a fear force
that makes you scared they call psych
and there's a time force who they just
called dion because that's his name
these were all real people that now have
these powers so barry time travels back
to stop them from being created in the
first place but now that he's here he
realizes that because they were created
out of his and iris's love they're kind
of like his children it turns out barry
is pro-life he decides to let them be
born yeah they really lean into this
whole urar children thing it's super
awkward because they're full-grown
adults even awkwarder with the speed
force herself who has taken the form of
barry's dead mother it's weird so barry
wants to help his kids but the speed
force decides they're too dangerous so
attacks them yeah the evil speed force
is the villain so papa flash visits his
kids and convinces them all to be good
guys so it's a family feud as the forces
join forces against their evil sister in
a nonsense cgi battle where barry has to
run around a tornado for some reason but
in the end they defeat her with their
real superpower a heart-to-heart speech
that convinces her to be a good guy
again so with all this talk about their
children iris is like hey why don't we
make some kids for real oh barry and
iris getting it on and speedsters have a
built-in pregnancy test cause your
grown-up kid from the future will time
travel back to be like congrats you
knocked mom up yes nora xs is back but
she's got a surprise this time cause in
this new timeline barry and iris have
two kids she's got a younger speedster
brother bart but also traveling back
from the future is their villain
godspeed remember last season they
fought a few godspeeds that were all
like robots or clones or something well
now there's a whole bunch of them oh the
flash is way outnumbered but what's this
some more godspeeds show up and then
fight the other godspeeds yeah there's a
godspeed civil war they capture one of
them who explains why it's happening but
it's complete nonsense i didn't
understand it but the flash has to stop
it because if they keep doing bad slow
karate at each other they're gonna tear
this city apart but now the flash has
his kids for backup turns out though
godspeed really hates his son bart the
most yes godspeed is bart's arch nemesis
because in the future he kills his uncle
jay jay garrick yes he's the flash from
earth 3 but now that there's only one
earth i think he just lives in ohio or
something apparently in the future he
and bart become incredibly close but now
is when jay meets him for the first time
anyway the speed force comes back to
give all our speedsters a power up
including giving iris temporary speeds
to powers again so now we've got a bunch
of speedsters and it's a big ol
speedster battle but for some reason
there's just like infinite godspeeds
eventually they track down the real
godspeed but he's got amnesia so they
send a barry inside his head to talk to
him where he meets the real real
godspeed it's like alright man so what's
your deal and basically he just likes
being evil but he was not born with his
speed it's artificial he came from the
velocity x formula and if barry doesn't
give him natural speed he's gonna let
his civil war clones destroy the city
and so barry has no choice he gives the
villain exactly what he wants and oh the
real full godspeed is born again sucks
all of his clone robots into himself so
now godspeed's going to kill the flash
but oh who's this coming in the reverse
flash eobard thawne confusingly still
wearing harrison wells's face he's like
what's up barry i'm not gonna let this
guy kill you i have to kill you myself
so for now they're gonna team up so for
their final battle godspeed pulls a new
move and turns his speedster lightning
into a sword yeah it's lightsaber time i
mean yeah just why not in the end darth
godspeed's gonna win the stabbed by
reverse flash so godspeed was the big
bad villain for all of three episodes so
now reverse flash turns on barry but oh
barry's way faster now yes his speed
force mom daughter's power up like made
him way faster so reverse flash is like
i'm gonna be back later and so at the
end of season seven barry and iris
decide to have another wedding to renew
their vows i guess their first one was
kind of overshadowed by oliver and
felicity and this time they're upstaged
by their son from the future who's
proven his real superpower isn't speed
but singing and so barry and iris have a
slo-mo flash time kiss and that's where
flash season 7 comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies and if you loved
this recap check out the join button and
support the channel as a member